all right so Tara Reid who accused Joe
Biden of sexual assault claiming the
incident took place in 1993 tried to
derail his 2020 presidential campaign
she has defected to Russia
what the hell is going on here the
guardian reporting former Senate staffer
who made claim in 2020 appears on
Russian media alongside convicted
Russian agent in the United States Maria
boutina I'm still kind of in a daze but
I feel very good Reid told Sputnik the
Russian press outlet that supports Putin
while sitting with Maria boutina a
convicted Russian agent jailed in the
U.S but now A Member of Parliament in
Russia I feel very surrounded by
protection and safety now 59 Reed was a
staffer for Biden when he was a senator
from Delaware in 2020 she said that back
in 93 in a senate hallway he pushed her
against the wall and assaulted her Biden
denied it at her press appearance Reed
was described as a writer and publicist
former aide to Joe Biden
sitting next to boutina Reid said I just
really so appreciate Maria and everyone
who's been giving me protection at a
time when it's been very difficult to
know if I'm safe or not I just didn't
want to walk home and walk into a cage
or be killed which is basically my two
choices so she has indeed defected to
Russia she says it was difficult she's
not impulsive she takes her time
and what she could see was that uh I
guess with the 24 election gearing up
she's better off in Russia being safe
she wants to live in both places but she
may only live in Russia and that's okay
so I want to talk about this for a very
specific reason
some on the right back when Tara Reid
made these allegations against Joe Biden
some on the right called the left out as
Hypocrites and what those on the right
said to those on the left was listen on
the one hand you leftists say we should
believe all women and then Tara Reid
comes forward forward and says Biden
assaulted me and you don't believe Tara
Reid and so it's important to understand
that believe all women in principle
doesn't mean
you blindly indefinitely believe every
single allegation and this has always
been the case this was what I said when
Justice Kavanaugh was accused this was
what I've always said the right wing
wants to use Tara Reid's allegations to
say that Democrats and leftists actually
have a double standard on me too and
that it's actually just a political tool
me too believe all women if the accused
is a republican but if it's Joe Biden
suddenly you don't believe all women and
this couldn't be further from reality
believe all women
has always meant if an alleged victim
comes forward you take that seriously
you understand that any time a victim
comes forward to say I was victimized
there is risk to them and that they
could be uh pushed one way or the other
stigmatize all these different things
and regardless of political affiliation
you investigate
that doesn't mean that every allegation
is automatically true or that the
allegations are free from scrutiny it
means every accuser should be heard and
respected and held accountable for the
truth and consistency of their claims
Tara Reid's claims were not consistent
and they did not appear to be true after
significant investigation believe all
women isn't a slogan that says You must
have unending Blind Faith period it is a
call to deal with systemic sexism and
misogyny the sort of stigma and
circumstances that historically have
silenced and dismissed women who have
experienced sexual violence it means we
want Justice we want accountability for
the perpetrators of such crimes
including those who have often escaped
punishment because they were in
positions of power or privilege we
recognize women are more likely to be
victims than they are Liars when it
comes to sexual assault
false claims of sexual assault and rape
are quite rare and when they happen they
should be dealt with seriously none of
this is new go back two years go back
five years go back 10 years this is what
I have been saying and when you looked
at the Tara Reid situation she made an
allegation and as far as I recall
certainly we took it very seriously okay
Joe Biden denied it fine many times
perpetrators deny things Joe Biden also
has a long record of supporting women's
rights and combating sexual violence in
contrast to Trump with his dozens of
accusations against him who doesn't have
that record Joe Biden said I will
cooperate with any investigation I will
release all relevant records related to
Tara Reid Donald Trump did not do that
and the contrast couldn't be more
glaring so what we need to understand is
that these right Wingers are desperate
to call the Tara Reid story
a story of hypocrisy because on some
level they must realize that when we say
believe all women we're not saying
unquestionably accept all allegations
with no scrutiny it's a reminder that we
take allegations seriously we support
the survivors we conduct thorough
investigations we ascertain the truth
and I can't think of any case that
better encapsulates that than the Tara
Reid situation and now that she has been
praising Putin and has defected to
Russia in my mind it only raises even
more doubts about her motivations and
her agenda and her allegiances so there
it is sort of like the cherry on top
Tara Reid has now defected to Russia